[Music]
what's happening right now
is a disaster this is not the la rams
this is the color of uh ukrainian flag i
thought zelinski was a clown
but now i
i know he has the biggest balls
in the universe my heart really goes out
to ukraine
save ukraine nowhere in ukraine support
ukraine
i really wish that all world leaders
right now just really come with a
logical conclusion if i could say
something to
mr president putin stop this attack
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
mr president putin
death and destruction
and it's all on you
manchester city all showing their
support wearing ukrainian colors on
their chest
with a very clear message
the everton players
draped in the ukraine flag
they are all brothers in arms tonight
united in their desire for peace showing
their solidarity and support for
everyone
suffering at the hands of russia
in ukraine
to all my russian readers and russian
friends
please now react
say what you what you feel
refuse this stupid dictator
stop it you cannot
remain silent you're not allowed
to remain silent
foreign
[Music]
for us french artists cartoonists you
represent freedom you represent bravery
against this tyranny and this invasion
attack to ukraine
is attack to all of us
is
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
you